I think the general idea it's your life
you get to run it the way you want to is
an appealing aspect of libertarianism I
am Nicholas we with reason TV and today
we're talking with the executive vice
president of the Cato Institute David
Bose a longtime libertarian activist and
premier thinker David thanks for talking
to us thank you the exact event that
we're dealing with here is the
libertarian mind it's a revised and
updated edition of libertarian as a
primer a book I reviewed for Reason in
97 and I am happy to say maybe that's
why I'm here I gave it a rave review
it's subtitled now a manifesto for
freedom so let's let's talk about the
libertarian mind how talk a bit about
how you define libertarianism in the
book in the very first line of the new
book I say libertarianism is the
philosophy of freedom so that's the
easiest thing the sentence that I
developed when I was talking about this
book on the radio many years ago was
libertarianism is the idea that adult
individuals have the right and the
responsibility to make the important
decisions about their own lives then of
course I go on in the book to say well
what does this mean it means economic
freedom and civil liberties and I think
a non interventionist foreign policy
it means the protection of individual
rights through limited government yeah
and I mean the idea of limiting the
government is to give more space to
individuals to kind of experiment or
innovate or come up with the way they
want to live their lives and you stress
this through out calling on various
thinkers from the past as long as
they're not infringing on the equal
rights of others all right one shorthand
that gets used a lot for libertarianism
and I think it comes up in various kind
of iterations and deviations in your
book is also you know that libertarians
tend to be socially liberal and fiscally
conservative what is the truth in that
and what's the limitation of that well
you know I I say that a lot when I'm
talking to journalists or when I'm
talking politics as you know David says
when you're talking to very stupid
people journalists and politician as you
know David Kirby and I did several study
on the libertarian vote and obviously
there we're not talking about people who
read recent magazine every month or have
read my book we're talking about we
think tens of millions of people who are
basically socially liberal and fiscally
conservative and I think what's
important about that politically is that
it sets them apart from the red base of
the Republican Party and the blue base
of the Democratic Party and therefore if
people know I'm fiscally conservative
and socially liberal or some of my
colleagues prefer to say socially
tolerant right then you should know that
you're not necessarily you're not a
fully comfortable Republican or Democrat
and that means you should be open to
thinking of yourself as independent and
maybe even grasping that you're kind of
libertarian and and this is also a way
of stressing that libertarianism is
really a pre political designation don't
you think I mean there is a libertarian
party which is important and we can talk
about that but a small L libertarian it
it can inform your your vote but it's
also it exists before kind of a partisan
tag oh yeah I think that's absolutely
right libertarianism is a philosophy
it's an attitude or a sense of life it
may be just sort of a sense of life that
I can make better decisions for myself
than other people can it may be a more
developed political philosophy even to
the extent everything the government
does seems to screw up so why don't we
have less government or it can be a more
fully developed political philosophy but
in any of those cases it doesn't
necessarily tell you to get involved in
politics or how to get involved and you
know one note on page 125 which I came
across and in my reading and this spoke
to me too is that you also stress that
libertarianism is not it's a political
philosophy it's not quote a complete
guide to life talk a little bit about
that well libertarianism is about the
relationship of the individual in the
state so it says what rights we have
with respect to each other
and it says what rights we have with
respect to the government and what
powers the government should have but
beyond that the the famous communitary
philosopher said the language of Rights
is morally incomplete yeah no kidding
it's a it's actually a very minimal set
of rules don't hit other people and
don't take their stuff and then we build
a legal system around those very simple
rules but it doesn't tell you how to
treat your spouse or how to treat your
friends or how to treat your employees I
know they're businessmen who say I apply
libertarian insights in my business and
they may and those may work for them but
there's nothing inherently libertarian
there's nothing libertarianism mandates
about how you treat people other than
not hitting them and taking their stuff
but could a libertarian do that or do
you really have to be if you're a
libertarian and your politics do you
have to be a libertarian in your
personal life well I've known enough
libertarians to know they don't have to
treat other people nicely so I don't
think it's very likely you know it's
like you have to be a pretty doctrinaire
libertarian if you just don't like gay
people but you still support gay rights
similarly if you are a real misanthrope
and you want to treat people badly and
particularly treat them as if they were
not autonomous individuals now as a
legal matter you have to but yes you
could say I'm gonna pay good wages but
I'm not gonna give you a moment's peace
if you work for me
that doesn't seem a likely thing that a
person with libertarian sensibilities
would do but yeah as a libertarian I
would say if you want to make that offer
to people and people want to come and
accept whatever salary you're offering
for bad working conditions but they have
a right to do it now you talk in the
book I mean you identify with the
natural rights or a natural law
tradition there you know versus
consequentialism utilitarianism various
other reasons talk a little bit about
the natural right tradition and how that
influences your libertarianism so
natural rights to me means I hold this
truth to be self-evident that everybody
has a right to live his own life the way
he chooses so long as he doesn't
interfere with the equal rights of
others and I think that
can be traced back to Aristotle Aquinas
Locke mill Herbert Spencer and into the
20th century even in the Austrian
economist though they're generally
regarded as consequentialist I think you
see the notions of treating people as
rights bearing individuals and then in a
more modern era - I'm Rand in Murray
Rothbard but I want people to understand
this is not something invented in the
late 20th century by Rand and Rothbart
it has a long history but it is the idea
that we have rights as individuals and
if we set up government it's to protect
those rights and that of government I
mean going back to the Declaration you
know that a right government that does
not respect those rights actually
deserves to be overthrown or
legitimately
right to alter or abolish it yeah but
you talked about the how many of the
things we consider a kind of libertarian
core of belief especially and in rights
in yourself or rights to act the way
that you want stem actually from a
religious kind of religious based
revolution in 17th century England talk
a little bit about the Levellers and
about the English Civil War and how the
libertarianism is widely considered a
haven for atheists but in fact you make
an argument that much of what we
consider libertarian thought really
started in a religious based civil war
well in going back even before that I
think you can say that a lot of the
fundamental ideas of libertarianism
developed through the judeo-christian
theory of the autonomous individual the
thinking individual the natural law the
individual who gets to read the Bible
and have a personal relationship with
Jesus we all have a soul so we we are
God's property in some sense not each
other's well that's right and you and
you can trace that back to give unto God
what is God's and under Caesar what is
Caesar's which establishes that there
are things that are not Caesars right we
may have to discuss what they are from
but that establishes the government
doesn't own your whole life it doesn't
own the whole world and then when you
get to the English Civil War yes a lot
of fur men in the 17th century
dissatisfaction with
the Stewart's who were perceived as
coming in and trying to change the
traditional English Constitution with
the rights of Englishmen and irrigate
more power into the monarchy and people
started objecting to that and we've got
robust debates going on and there were a
group of people called the Levellers
like most political labels this was
given to them by their opponents all
they wanted to do was level rights they
believed in equal freedom under law they
didn't believe in leveling Society there
was in fact another group of people who
called themselves the true Levellers and
they really were they were like
socialists and other people call them
the diggers because they went out and
dug up the land of the aristocrats but
the Levellers were putting together a
program based on their Christian faith
originally and the autonomy of every
individual and the responsibility that
every individual has to God not to the
king the king is only there so long as
he respects our rights and so they
talked about individualism individual
rights religious freedom because there
were arguments going on there between
the Catholic Church
Henry's Episcopal Church and then people
who actually want in real Protestantism
yeah that freedom of conscience the
freedom to worship God as you saw fit
that's right and so those kinds of
things merged with their political
theory their defence of property rights
their defense of manhood suffrage to
create what we could consider the first
recognizably libertarian political
platform no and of course it also
harkens back even to a pre-christian era
with I'm thinking of and I'm it's
mentioned in the book you know plays
like Antigone and whatnot which is all
about a person who refuses to follow the
mandates of the political leader because
she is answering to a higher law that's
right so well talked about what is the
evidence for the fact that we're in a
kind of libertarian moment or a
libertarian
well we've tried to announce the
libertarian moment several times but we
might be in better shape here one of the
things certainly is in my view one of
the things that creates libertarian
moments is government overreach
and people see government is getting too
big and it isn't working very well
so you had a financial crisis there's a
big argument over what caused that was
it ray patience unfettered capitalism on
Wall Street or was it shaped by bad
decisions of the Federal Reserve causing
massive mistakes in the market and to
the extent that a significant number of
people accepted that latter point its
Federal Reserve and over-regulation that
caused it that pushes people in a
libertarian direction and certainly you
were saying the overreach I mean
whatever caused that the correction of
saying okay we're bailing out we're
bailing out auto manufacturers was never
popular we're bailing out banks not
popular yes that's right so in September
of 2008 you have this crash start to
happen and you have the government
respond really in a completely
undelivered way my memory of that fall
is every Monday morning the head of the
Fed the Secretary of the Treasury and
the head of the New York Fed would
announce what they did over the weekend
to destroy the remains of the free
enterprise system and we just felt like
small government people felt like we
were being slapped in the face every
Monday morning with these announcements
and it was a very depressing time to be
a libertarian or a small government
person and obviously a president
promising a big expanded view of
government was about to get elected and
then announced both a health care
takeover and a huge biggest spending
bill in the history of the world but the
other thing that starts going on during
this period is a push back sales of
Atlas Shrugged start soaring sales of
the Road to Serfdom start soaring sales
of potato Institute's pocket
Constitution our pocket Constitution
made the Washington Post bestseller list
in October of 2008 so there's that push
back and then and and then the rise of
the Tea Party which although not a
libertarian movement exactly was a
libertarian force in American politics
it was against big government big
spending big debt health care takeover
simultaneously starting into really on
Election Day 2008
gay marriage is defeated in
and Barack Obama and Hillary Clinton and
all the Republicans are against it and
it looks like Wow just took a big hit
and then over the coming year judges and
legislators in more states start
endorsing gay marriage and you have a
movement that happens and it eventually
within four short years gets so big
that Barack Obama has a long dark night
of the soul and changes his mind and now
he's in favor of it simultaneously you
have a marijuana legalization movement
that's been around for many years I had
a New York Times op-ed in 1988 on why we
should end the drug war but suddenly
around 2008 2010 it starts actually
winning a couple of elections so all of
those things I think are part of the
libertarian moment and then you folks at
Reason have stretched much more than
than I do
the cultural aspects of the libertarian
moment new technologies that are
allowing people to make their own music
publish their own books publish their
own magazines find their own cab drivers
all sorts of things that feel more
libertarian and give more people the
sense that they can make decisions in
the marketplace that they weren't making
before you know in in the work that
you've done on kind of the electorate
and polling data and whatnot talk a bit
about how swing voters or not swing
voters per se but how the pool of
independent voters of unaffiliated
voters seems to be growing and does that
feed in to this sense that the you know
things are more up for grabs people are
less interested in being an old-style
Republican or Democrat or even an
old-style liberal or conservative there
are a lot of political scientists who
say there aren't really any independence
that if you push them they admit oh yeah
I always vote Republican that sort of
thing but still the number of people who
say their independence is growing and
that certainly shows increasing
dissatisfaction with both parties in
particular the Democratic Party which
has always had a plurality of the
electorate losing that now two
independent right and what our work
shows is that a large percentage of
those independents are in fact Liberty
in the sense that they are shall we say
socially liberal and fiscally
conservative now some of them and this
is one reason you can't organize the
independence some people are independent
in swing voters because they're socially
conservative and fiscally liberal and we
sometimes call them populist voters
they're basically anti libertarian on a
range of things on the other hand
they're very anti-establishment they
don't like the big boys in Washington
and so I think a candidate maybe it's
Ronald Reagan maybe it's Rand Paul a
candidate who can appeal to that
anti-establishment anti-washington ethos
might pick up some of those people even
though ideologically you'd think he
should well talk about you know recent
governor's race in Virginia which you
know the the Democratic candidate was
Terry McAuliffe is very closely tied to
the to the Clintons is kind of a
standard Democrat liberal democratic
liberal Ken Cuccinelli had been
Virginia's Attorney General was a very
kind of standard-issue Republican very
socially conservative but also pretty
small government at least in many of his
proclamations and then there was a
libertarian candidate Robert Sarvis who
got what eight or nine percent of the
vote I think he only got 10 or 12 in
rolls yeah and and he more than covered
the gap I believe between them although
exit polls show that he pulled more from
McAuliffe than from cuccinelli which is
fascinating but you know is that is this
kind of a test case of where you know if
Cuccinelli or McAuliffe could have
appealed to swing voters they would have
you know Cuccinelli might have triumphed
or the margin of victory for McAuliffe
would have been much bigger well sure if
either one of them could have picked up
a substantial number of services 7% then
he could have won a comfortable victory
I do think what you had there was a
really right-wing Republican and a
really corrupt hustler Liberal Democrat
and so it was kind of tailor-made for a
third party to actually get some
attention and I know the Libertarian
Party is thinking boy if we actually had
some money or if the media covered us
think what we could have gotten in a
race with those two
very flawed candidates but yeah I think
Sarvis showed that there is this group
of people who will even vote for a
libertarian if they hear his name and if
you kind of had and an essence of
Republican an essence of Democrat
candidate and a lot of people didn't
like them there seems to be part of the
kind of libertarian moment or an
ascendancy I mean there's certainly you
know for the and I think in the first
time in my life people are seriously
talking about a libertarian wing to the
Republican Party where did that come
from and is that is that for real
well I I said to Rand Paul the other day
I keep reading these headlines about
libertarian wing of the Republican Party
and I'm like who is this wing it's Rand
Paul yeah well it may be a couple of us
and there's a couple of others and I do
think that the Tea Party and Rand Paul
together have made people think oh
there's some kind of libertarian wing
the election of Justin Amash and Thomas
Massie and to some extent the election
of Mike Lee and even Ted Cruz are
perceived as being different from
establishment conservatives even though
it's not clear they're actually
libertarian but they're at least very
strongly free-market and ticked off
about the way the government is trying
to run the economy so there's that kind
of libertarian wing but it's also true
if you look at votes take the emotion
Menma to restrain the NSA it split both
parties got about 40 percent of both
parties in its initial vote on the hill
and so that suggests well there was a
libertarian wing of the Republican Party
maybe even a libertarian wing of REMIC
radical party and what we haven't been
talking about here is foreign policy and
I think 13 years of war has caused even
a lot of Republicans to say when is this
ever going to end why are we doing this
and they're now saying a majority I
think of a Republicans this war was a
mistake so Rand Paul has been the person
leading that effort but there are other
people starting to talk about enough so
that neo-cons are complaining about an
isolationist wing in the Republican
Party and I I'm acht them in 2012 and
said
the neocon said there was isolated is
talk in the Republican debate excuse me
from the former US Trade Representative
John Huntsman from the International
businessman Mitt Romney who are these
people who are isolationist these are
people who are saying you know maybe
we're in enough Wars and it's time to
write wind them down so that's some
change in thinking well talk about yeah
where is the libertarian case or the
libertarian appeal do you think the
strongest and foreign policy is
certainly one of these we've majorities
of people saying now anyway that the
invasion of Iraq was a mistake that
Afghanistan it's not clear what it
achieved or where actually what when
we're still there I mean we have 15,000
troops talk about why people be is there
something beyond just kind of fatigue of
failure well there are two fundamental
things that go on in American
understanding of foreign policy I think
one is generally a lack of interest in
running the rest of the world we have
these two big oceans we don't have to
get involved all over the world and a
lot of Americans are perfectly happy not
to we don't speak very many foreign
languages and that kind of plays into we
don't need to do that but there's also
this scotch-irish
attitude that if anybody kicks us we're
gonna kick back and so when you see
beheadings or the attack on 9/11 or
anything like that you get a very strong
push among the American public to hit
back now the libertarian argument of
course is if you didn't if you weren't
over in Iraq then Isis wouldn't be
beheading Americans so stay out of
conflicts and you won't have to get into
further conflicts I think the driver yes
okay well I I mean because it's it's
yeah I mean in a broad sense but then in
local census it's not clear you know if
you're beheading freelance journalist
covering the Syrian civil war well you
know yes that's your right but most of
what goes on in the Middle East I think
in first place there wouldn't be a
broken Iraq if it weren't for our Iraq
war their problem there might not be a
Syrian civil war now maybe it's a good
thing that people want to get rid of
saude but it wouldn't be drawing us in
and so no I don't think it would be the
same thing if we had not already been at
war there then you wouldn't have the
same desire to go in and fight there so
that is an appealing aspect of
libertarianism but it does come up
against this we hit back when somebody
hears us but then there's also in in
Washington and it seems to me this is
part of the pushback there is also a
military-industrial complex you know
which Eisenhower are obviously famously
named and warned against but you know
because people all over this place and
in many parts of the country that get a
lot of defense dollars like what the
they don't really care about being
overseas they just want to make sure
that the 500 or 600 billion dollars a
year that are the baseline defense
budget doesn't get cut and in fact grows
well and if all that the defense budget
cost us was the five or six billion
dollars then that would be better than
going to war and costing us lives and
entanglement but but it is more than
that and I think actually foreign policy
is an area where libertarians have the
libertarian argument has more resonance
with the people than it does with the
elites but because people tend not to
vote on foreign policy issues that means
the elites get to run things so you've
got a liberal internationalist
establishment in the Democratic Party
and a neocon establishment in the
Republican Party and those two together
though they would have trouble winning
an election or a referendum in the whole
country nevertheless control Washington
and talk a little bit I mean - I mean
libertarians don't shrink from an
integrated world no I think the whole
term isolationism there are a few
Americans who are isolationist
traditionally some people didn't like
international trade they didn't want to
learn languages or go overseas and they
didn't want our troops overseas so
that's isolationism and Pat Buchanan
might be an example of that today but
libertarians are very much cosmopolitan
we want to trade we want cultural
interaction we want to get books and
ideas and people were open to liberal
immigration rules the one thing we want
to
minimize is political and military
intervention in the rest of the world so
that's simply not isolationism its
non-interventionism right right and non
military intervention ISM where are
other places that you think the
libertarian case or the Liberty the
libertarian appeal is at its strongest
and well I think primarily one of the
strongest appeals is don't raise taxes
in fact cut taxes and it's disappointing
to me that the taxpayer movement has
never been more successful than it has
been because it is very hard to win with
the general public an argument that we
shouldn't do more for education do more
for health care do more for
transportation where you can win is it's
going to cost money so we shouldn't tax
more and we shouldn't go into more debt
those two things no debt and low taxes I
think are very strongly resonant with
the Putnam one of the problems though is
that well if you keep cutting taxes but
you don't cut spending you get into a
very bad situation and it seems that
politicians have learned that you can
actually cut taxes and keep spending
more and more I mean this is the lesson
of the George Bush presidency or the
lesson of the Reagan presidency that's
right actually the lesson of all
presidencies since probably Eisenhower
well that's right and I think among
libertarian scholars there's a lot of
argument over this should you starve the
beast or does does cutting taxes without
cutting spending lead people to say a
spending is free I think which we hear
about now well I mean Paul Krugman for
instance says we would be idiots given
the interest rates are so low we should
be taking on as much debt as we can
because it's never going to be this
cheap again well that again I think it's
an elite argument or appeals to
Democratic spenders but does not have
much resonance with the American public
I think no debt and low taxes have much
stronger popular appeal and we argue
about what is the practical impact I
still pretty much come down on Milton
Friedman's side that you want to cut
taxes and cut spending whenever you get
the opportunity but I appreciate that
James Buchanan and build a scannin or
very smart advocates of limited
government and they had a different view
of this I mean they would argue actually
that you know
when you raise taxes or they claim
anyway or show that you raise taxes and
spending will actually go down because
people suddenly realize what they're
paying for and weld lasted there were
arguments about that and my sense is
that bill niskanen sort of changed his
mind on that he did not believe this
idea of a grand bargain raise taxes and
cut spending was going to work although
he had at an earlier point what else is
there are there others so we're you know
foreign policy taxes what else is
another big appeal for libertarianism
like that well I think the general idea
it's your life you get to run it the way
you want to is an appealing aspect of
libertarianism unfortunately in
political terms many voters are
susceptible to saying that in principle
but then would be but then upon being
told that what some other person wants
to do is smoke marijuana or engage in a
homosexual relationship or worship the
wrong God in different periods of
American history people have reacted
against that and liberals modern
American style liberals not us classical
liberals will tend to say sure people
should be able to make their own
decisions oh but not if that means not
contributing to the public good by
paying 50 percent income taxes or not
selling cakes to gay people right we're
not selling gay cakes to homophobes
right homophobe so well that's making me
org or if you start saying the wrong
thing so where do you think the
libertarian case or libertarian appeal
is the weakest where a place is that
still you know large numbers of people
need convincing that libertarianism is a
smart way to think about the world or we
might persuade them well you're talking
about Americans right yeah because in a
whole lot of the world right I know
religious yes no problem right in
America I think probably the drug war is
still something that even though we're
starting to win a couple of votes on
marijuana we're a long way from
persuading people that other drugs
should be legal and that's an issue
libertarians have talked a lot about it
probably is associated with libertarians
in the minds of Reid
we inform people so that's been a
challenge for us although it's one we
have talked about what about immigration
because this is something and you know I
know a smattering of libertarians who
are kind of anti-immigration you know
for various reasons but overwhelmingly
libertarians we believe in the the flow
of goods and services across borders and
we believe in the free movement of
people that seems to be a radically
unpopular point of view in contemporary
America I don't think it's radically
unpopular I think if you look at the
polls
most people are reasonably sympathetic
to a moderately liberal immigration
policy they believe immigration is good
for America they believe that we should
be open to immigration they believe we
should control our borders and control
the flow but they're generally Pro
immigration however there are a
significant number of people who we
would generally regard as being Pro free
market and anti-big government anti
federal government who are vociferously
anti-immigration and so yes in terms of
sort of putting together a political
majority yeah there are people who don't
like immigration what do you think
drives the anti-immigrant sentiment
particularly my kind of conservative
Republicans they seem to be the most
vocal well you know to some extent
conservative reaction that's what it is
change people don't like change my
scotch-irish ancestors came to this
country before the Declaration of
Independence and I'm sure along the way
they didn't like the Germans and they
didn't like the Irish and they didn't
like the Jews and Italians and now they
don't like the Hispanics there's a
zero-sum economics attitude that they
will come in and take our jobs which is
a misunderstanding of whether the
economy works there is clearly some
element of simply of opposition to
difference racial difference it's a
tribalism or rebel ISM yes there is that
and there is also going along with it of
somewhat legitimate attitude about rule
of law these people are here illegally
my ancestors or my cousins waited in
line now I always say to the the
anti-immigration people like like pat
buchanan you know when your ancestors
came in the 19th century my ancestors
were sitting here waiting for them and
they grumbled about it but there were no
restrictions you were allowed to come in
so when you say your ancestors were
legal they were only legal because there
were no barriers so what would your
ancestors do if Ireland was suffering a
potato famine and America had
restrictions on immigration
they might just come in anyway but
they're but it's a legitimate concern
that things should happen according to
the law but then there always seems to
be the you know with the unwillingness
the saying therefore we if we change the
laws and allow more people of migrate
legally
problems there's a problem of illegal
them to say why don't we change the law
talk a little bit about kind of global
warming oh yeah I want to finish
answering your question about what's
most difficult because one of the very
difficult things for us to sell to a
whole lot of people is the idea that
specific things the government will do
for you are a bad idea that the
government in fact doesn't run good
schools it doesn't run good health care
it's not even the best way to build
roads and and and bridges and all of
these things together it will be built
inefficiently and they will cost a lot
of money and the stuff you think is free
will end up costing you more than you
would have paid for it in the
marketplace so just the general idea of
government as Santa Claus is a real
obstacle to a libertarian or any other
small government fiscally conservative
politic and I think some libertarians
flatter themselves to say well you know
the difference is that we think
systematically and other people just
aren't that evolved but how much of it
is constantly linking the I mean I know
tons of people with you know many
degrees and all of this who will say
well look the reason you know I don't
think the government should be doing
that but I get a National Science
Foundation grant and the government
should definitely be funding that I mean
is it one of the ways that we persuade
more people to the efficacy or the
effectiveness or the goodness of
libertarianism is by kind of trying to
create more systemic thinkers or more
systemic thinkers well yes it's probably
good if people are more assist
Matic thinkers on the other hand there
are plenty of PhDs
Paul Krugman wanted nobel prize in
economics and yet he doesn't agree with
us on very much so we we can't just say
if people were smarter and I think
matter it's still probably good for the
world if people can think more logically
but it's not an automatic ticket to
winning one of the things you point out
though is that each new government
program creates a new constituency so
the National Science Foundation grants
or the childcare subsidies or the
highway for your district all of those
things create people who were not
previously advocates of big government
but now we're required to rally around
to defend the farm subsidies or whatever
so one of the reasons that we so very
much want to stop these new programs is
each one creates a new constituency
which then in order to get its
concentrated benefit is willing to add
pennies to its tax bill to pay for
everybody else yes well talk about
global warming or global warming and
environmentalism this seems to be a case
where I think there are very strong
libertarian arguments about ways forward
but it often comes up as one of the
places where well this is where you know
libertarianism has you know no way of
solving this or even acknowledging that
you know collective action is needed to
stop the planet from boiling in its own
juices what what is the libertarian
response well I think it's I think it's
a difficult issue I don't think that you
solve that problem by saying I have no
systemic theory and no rules on what I
think the government should do anything
that looks good to me I'm for what is
your political philosophy that defines
what's appropriate for the government
and what's not or is it that you think
everything is the purview of the
government but for libertarians yeah
it's an issue as far as global warming
goes my own view based on Pat Michaels
work at Cato we're the only think-tank
with an actual climatologist on the
staff is that the globe is warming it's
partly man-made but it's not going to be
catastrophic the globe has warmed and
cooled over the centuries in the
millennia and
and there's no evidence that it's going
to be particularly dangerous however
that doesn't mean that in theory it
couldn't be or that a hole in the ozone
layer or something else like that could
be devastating and then you have public
action problems and yes I think
libertarians should think more carefully
about what we would do if that were the
case and I don't know that I have a good
answer other than decentralization try
to avoid command and control solutions a
strict respect for property rights
typically gets you better answers and
better internalization of costs and and
by that it also I mean you're implying
as well that you know South Florida
which has had bad weather for a long
time does a you know in Holland for that
instance they do a pretty good job of
coping with environmental variance and
then catastrophe in a way that
Bangladesh doesn't well that's that's
right so the most important thing to
solving a lot of these problems like the
spread of Ebola in Africa or the threat
of exaggerated hurricanes here is wealth
create more wealth our buildings are
much less likely to fall down because
we're a wealthy country and we value
having buildings that don't fall down in
Bangladesh they may value them but they
don't have the money in Africa in the
countries affected by Ebola they just
have not created enough prosperity to be
able to afford the medical
infrastructure that would make Ebola
easily manageable so the answer to
healthcare problems in Africa to many of
the world's environmental problems is
have a more prosperous world create more
wealth which can then be spent on the
real challenge what are the best ways to
Goose economic growth well we may be
because of demographic reasons or
whatever be in a period where growth
can't be as high as it could have been
on the other hand it was running at 3%
before that China's been running at 9%
they had a lot of catching up to do but
still I'm betting we could do better
than 3% if we had lower taxes less
regulation on the
me less cronyism and protection for
established businesses take uber as an
example here we have this 50 year old
taxi cartel in every city in every state
and a new business comes along and wants
to break up that cartel and provide more
service better competition to people and
the cartel fights back so breaking up
cartels from the taxis to the banks to
whatever is one way to do it to open up
the economy get more entrepreneurship
get more things happening but the
burdens of taxes and regulation make
that difficult how how do you and
they're already instances where uber is
starting to form a new cartel I mean
they're dealing in places like
Washington DC and whatnot and it's an
understandable business move you you
know you show up in a city you do pretty
well you get enough of a customer base
so you can push back against the taxi
Commission but then at some point you
want to sue for peace all right and keep
other people out what is the is is that
a you know just part of the free market
I mean almost that big government and
big business work handing by some
perfect free-market ok well part of the
political let me put it it's an
excrescence of the free market because
once you have a wealthy business you can
start spending more money on things one
of the things you do is spend it on
political favors
well yes except that if we had a more
strictly applied Constitution or had
written the Constitution more strictly
in the first place and government wasn't
allowed to create monopolies for
instance then it wouldn't do you any
good
to to pay politicians to create a
monopoly so in a free-market protected
by law that actually guarantees a free
market then this would be less of a
problem in our current politicized
market than it is I just read the
Virginia legislature on a bipartisan
basis is sitting down with uber and lyft
to discuss rules to enable them to
operate the first rule is they have to
pay a hundred thousand dollars for a
license well uber can afford that but
there might be a lot of potential
Uber's who can't afford a hundred
thousand dollars so yes that absolutely
looks like the established players now
including uber and
lift will be able to get some barriers
to entry created by the legislature what
are the challenges you know these I mean
in talking about some of the places
where libertarianism is appealing and
somewhere perhaps needs to do more work
to persuade more people there are some
more serious challenges to the kind of
libertarian paradigm I think and last
year saw the publication and in in
English of thomas piketty's book about
capital you know where he's basically
saying that we are now entering a kind
of it's not even a new Gilded Age but
where it's just that the returns to the
haves it's just going to continue
exponentially where the have-nots are
just locked out because you know
individual laborers can't catch up to
the returns on capital do you see that
as a fundamental challenge to or a
credible challenge to a kind of
libertarian free-market person well I
suppose it's a credible challenge I'm
not an economist and I certainly am no
expert on what's good or bad in pick
ADIZ work I do think as a political
matter piketty's book made an argument
that was attractive to the world leading
media and so it was immediately hailed
as the most important book of the decade
and so on and and there were no critics
because who's read it it's 800 pages in
it's a brand-new book and so the media
report he shows this and then after the
month-long media hype economists start
actually plowing their way through it
and my understanding is that they have
come up with significant questions about
the theory of the increasing returns to
capital serious questions about the
actual data in the book and so on so
five years from now how influential
picot East book B I don't know but it
made a big difference there but yes
inequality and the perception of
inequality is a big issue one thing I
think libertarians say possibly isn't
always compelling to people is would you
rather be equal at low incomes or
unequal at high incomes higher incomes
every day that Microsoft stock goes up
the gap between me and Bill Gates gets
greater but you know I have a little
microsoft stock so I make 10 dollars
that day
he makes a hundred million dollars that
day but I don't see that as bad for me
so in general it seems to me the problem
we ought to be concerned about is
poverty and the stagnation of
middle-class wages so rather than
focusing on we don't want Bill Gates to
be rich or get richer we should focus on
what are we doing wrong that might
improve the problem of poverty or
middle-class incomes right now is that
really where the battle is being drawn
because any inequality a lot of people
react negatively to the idea of
inequality it does seem you know it
seems to be growing the gap between the
richest Americans and the poorest
Americans middle class incomes seem to
be stagnating and what people you know
even when Obama was talking in a State
of the Union address he wasn't talking
about you know what I'm going to go
after those you know malefactors of
wealth that you know billionaires it's
it ends up attacking people who are in
the top 10% or the top 20% and does you
know does libertarian you know so it's
not it's not that Bill Gates gets rich
but it's that somebody who's making
twice or three times as much as me who
is basically I have the same education
we started at at the same place that
seems to be where the the rub comes
isn't it well I'm not sure about that it
seems to me that what we hear about is
billionaires and billionaires are in a
completely different right place yes
there has been some stretching out of
middle-class incomes charles murray
talks about how it you know used to be
if you were good at math you could
become an engineer and make twice as
much as the factory worker but now if
you're good at math you can become a
Wall Street quant
and make a hundred times what the
factory worker does that may seem unfair
but the economy the market is about
satisfying human needs and if it turns
out that your skills once not very
useful are now incredibly useful to
making our economy work better and to
provide more real wealth for people then
that's a good thing
I saw a chart of incomes from 1979 on by
the various income classes the other day
what it shows was that the bottom four
quintiles
all up roughly 40% in that period top
20% up twice that much top 1% up a
thousand percent
okay that is rising inequality but it's
also significant increases in living
standards for all Americans and that
seems to me better than what I think
would be the results of seriously trying
to constrain any colonists is Obama
talking to Joe the Plumber or even in
you know the State of the Union well why
don't we just take some of that extra
wealth at the top and spread it around a
little bit more that's fair well that's
right and it's easy to say that that's
fair and if you if you take a little bit
extra from the billionaires really are
they gonna stop working but as you were
saying it's not just the billionaires
who will be hit by these taxes it is the
people who are currently working and
building businesses because you can't
get that much from billionaires and if
you try to take a lot of what they have
then yes they will stop creating
companies and they will stop working
it's a bad thing for America and for the
world that Bill Gates stopped working
because he had enough money and went
into philanthropy he was brilliant at
creating new connections and new wealth
for society it's too bad he's not doing
that I suspect many Microsoft employees
would agree with you yeah you should
have kept working here's another
possible challenge to a kind of
libertarian paradigm which is
Millennials and I know that you've done
some work on Millennials reason has done
a long pole an in-depth poll and
Millennials on a certain level are very
libertarian they hate things like you
know nanny state rules they hate soda
bands and they hate smoking bans and
they hate all you know they want more
choice in their lives they don't have
the same kind of sexual or or racial
hang-ups that older Americans have I
mean they're just they're very
cosmopolitan they're very loose they're
very free in that way but they also
believe that the government in a
majority of them believe that the
government should guarantee you health
care should guarantee you a job should
guarantee you lots of stuff is that
mentality a real standing challenge to a
libertarian parent oh I think it is you
know my friends who run students for
liberty and hemily
chickens who does this polling work keep
trying to convince me that Millennials
are essentially libertarian this is the
most libertarian generation ever and I
know since the last one yeah
but I look at those polls and I see that
Millennials seem to have an incredible
faith in a government that I think they
know has been a huge disappointment of
in a whole range of areas and yet they
want this magical government to provide
jobs provide housing and so on
now one answer to that may be that when
they get in the workforce and they start
paying taxes they'll have a different
view of how much the government should
do on the other hand Millennials
I think range up to age 29 so they're
either in the workforce and they're
paying taxes or they're not in the
workforce because our economic policies
are not working and so we may be in a
period of trying to argue to this
generation what is it that isn't working
is it the rapacious untrammeled
capitalism that isn't working or is it
the burden of taxes and regulation and
of course I think it is the burdens
we're placing on the market that are
causing so many young Millennials to not
be able to find jobs to still be in
their pajamas in their parents house for
health care yeah one of the things
that's interesting is libertarian
thought and the political philosophy
that it comes out of in the
Enlightenment and in the 19th century is
the belief that you and I and everybody
is an autonomous individual who should
be given wide latitude to make choices
in their life choices of you know who to
vote for they should be given the
franchise what to buy you know what to
wear how to how to organize there's your
life yeah and there's a lot of pushback
now or a lot or not maybe pushback but
there's a lot of investigation now
whether it's through evolutionary
psychology or or through even economics
which is saying wait hold on because
actually individuals are much more
suspect to or subject to forces that
direct and control them that we didn't
really pay attention to and so you have
people like Cass Sunstein talking about
you know nudging people or that creating
a framework which will direct people to
the right decision you have people who
follow advertised
and say look there's and this is an old
idea but that you know the hidden
persuaders and now we use a more
scientific term they're goading people
to buying certain things selling certain
things even Nobel prize-winning
economists like Vernon Smith who someone
we both know who is a phenomenal
libertarian and a really interesting
economist his experimental economics
really consistently shows I mean he'll
say that I can take freshmen and teach
them a couple of rules in a in a in an
investment system and within the second
or third trial we'll be doing exactly
what the system tells them to do is this
a kind of metaphysical challenge to the
idea that you know I would even say
maybe somebody like charles murray says
look some people just don't have the
wherewithal to really make the best
choices for their lives is the
libertarian paradigm at risk for from an
attack for people to say you know what
this idea that we're making meaningful
choices is just a bunch of hooey well we
may all be living in the matrix but the
thing about the matrix is you don't know
that so I am certainly not conversant
enough with all of these schools of
thought to have a rational opinion about
it I guess what I would say is society
works best if we let people make
decisions whatever way they're making
them we will get better results if we
act as if people have free will if they
have autonomy if we hold them
responsible for the consequences of
their actions even if there may be some
unfairness because really they they had
something in their brains causing them
to do this and we should continue to
study these things and maybe we'll find
out something better but I think we've
learned from trying socialism and
central planning and various and and
theocracy and various kinds of ways of
actually regulating through force what
choices people can make that you get
worse results so do you get ideal
results do you get perfect results from
people making their own decisions maybe
not but I think you get better results
than any other social political system
will give you then I mean this is an
interesting point that you raised
libertarianism is often accused of being
utopian but it really is profoundly anti
utopian because it's never talking about
the one best way or the final
breakthrough it's really about a kind of
process that allows people to discover
or society and individuals to discover
what they want and what they should be
right it's a discovery procedure it's a
framework for utopias you can try to set
up the way you'd like to live and I can
try to set up the way I'd like to live
and some of those ways will turn out to
be more attractive to people than others
and you know this this idea that that
advertisers or anybody else can shape
what we think yeah to some extent but
it's also true that sometimes they're
big-budget movies that fall flat on
their faces and there's the old story
about you know we've tried everything
with our advertising and we still can't
get people to buy the dog food why is
that and finally the intern says dogs
don't like it talk a little bit about
what are the challenges through a kind
of libertarian political movement or
social movement that you that you find
are profound or particularly challenging
well there are a lot of challenges to
our political movement right now there
aren't enough of us and we don't have
enough money to the extent that we do
have money it tends to go all into
economic issues regulation and taxes and
not into broader parts of libertarianism
that may itself connect to one of the
challenges we face is a lot of us grew
up in a world where kind of seemed like
everybody in America was white except
10% we're black and they didn't have a
whole lot of involvement in shaping
politics or a lot of us are men well
that's right and now we're in a much
more diverse world libertarianism has
the image sometimes of being a white
guy's club and so we need to work on
diversifying to have more women more
people of color involved and when we see
that among younger groups you definitely
see a more diverse group at students for
liberty than you do at an older donors
conference um you see a very much more
diverse group among Cato's interns than
among Cato's middle-aged policy staff so
I think that is partly changing but I
think it's also that we need to think
more about talking about issues of race
and class and talking in ways that
appeal beyond our logical Austria and
Randy an INTJ white guy syndrome you
know what you know what is the you you
talk about this in the book both in
terms of kind of feminism or gender
equity as well as racial equity
what is the libertarian you know line on
these things well the history is very
good libertarians are the heirs of
classical liberalism and who was it who
first after thousands of years
challenged slavery some Christians but
mostly Christians influenced by liberal
values who first said women are equal to
men classical liberals and proto
libertarians so and and of the same
thing with gay rights the only people
who challenge the the general societal
attitude toward homosexuality were
classical liberal and you point out that
the Libertarian Party in 1972 as part of
its platform had gay rights in it
wherever and I believe at that point it
was homosexuality was still considered a
mental illness at DSM and many states
yeah so yes so libertarians
have been ahead of the game you know up
through slavery Jim Crow and you point
out as well that you know there's kind
of a founding matriarchy really of the
content you know the post-war
libertarian movement in terms of vine'
Rand Isabel Patterson and Rose Wilder
Lane yes but this is kind of like Rand
Paul going to Howard and you know
stopping his genealogy of greatness in
about 1920 of you know what what
Republican how Republicans were good on
race so what are the you know what is
the contemporary pitch to say to women
and minorities that you know actually
the libertarian thought is is the place
that you should be looking at well I
think two women the the pitch is
absolutely we believe every individual
every adult individual is equal and
everybody should have the opportunity to
fulfill their dream to pursue their
dream as they
choose which might be being a homemaker
and it might be being a CEO and
everybody gets to make that choice and
to the extent that there are some
feminists who want the government to
take care of women whether that was
traditionally by barring them from
certain occupations or these days by
mandating them in certain occupations or
by guaranteeing childcare or birth
control or whatever while libertarians
have to disagree with that but
individualism and equal dignity where
we're there on with Hispanics we
obviously talked a lot about liberal
immigration rules we also talked about
this country being a land of opportunity
and let's make it more so and let's have
better schools and those are the things
that will help people rise with the
african-american community I mean I
think we did sort of for a generation
drop out of that battle and libertarians
need to get back in it and what can we
say to people in the african-american
community
well the Cato Institute runs police
misconduct not met we are the people
monitoring police misconduct around the
country we are the people criticizing
the drug war which brings such a heavy
military presence in criminal presence
prison presence into black communities
we're talking about giving poor people
more options in schooling and that would
be so much of a benefit to poor people
which disproportionately includes
african-americans let's talk a little
bit about your kind of personal Odyssey
to libertarianism you hail originally
from Western Kentucky I knew your
scots-irish so that means that the you
know family gatherings much must be
quite a combustible affair and
particularly if Kentucky Bourbon is is
involved but you know how did you watch
what your intellectual genealogy how did
you how did you start to become a
libertarian when did you start calling
yourself that well my parents were both
well-educated and conservative I grew up
sort of a Jeffersonian constitutional
conservative in my in my part of the
country we were still all Democrats back
then but Democrats who voted Republican
a lot of the time and so so I got
interested in these ideas and I thought
it might
as a conservative I guess I wasn't a
very rebellious kid at that time and so
my parents were conservative and that's
what I read I read Henry Hazlitt and I
pretty well learned all the economics I
was ever gonna learn you read economics
in one lesson and you got the lesson I
read Barry Goldwater's the conscience of
a conservative which is a very
libertarian book despite its title and
that gave me a framework for
understanding public policy and then
actually I read a couple of issues but I
ask you before we move off of Goldwater
how did how do you square his or in
conscience of a conservative or I guess
it was the later book why not victory
which was a brief for victory in Vietnam
and elsewhere you know a kind of massive
anti-communism which you know makes a
hell of a lot of sense but you know
there's a militaristic component to that
which Goldwater embraced but not fully I
think it was always against the draft
but I mean how you know what were you
more of a conventional conservative of
we've got to go over there to we've got
to be on the Korean Peninsula we've got
to be an Indochina we've got to be
everywhere where the the bugs might show
up and get them before you know they
take over land at that time I was pretty
conventional conservative as you know it
was pretty common for conservatives who
thought that the federal government
couldn't do anything competently except
maybe deliver the mail
nevertheless thought it could have this
massive military establishment throwing
its weight around the world confronting
communism all over when I was 14 years
old my first published article was a
call for victory in Vietnam so yes I and
on the side of the South Vietnamese
right yes okay so well so then so you
you encounter Goldwater you've read
Henry hayslett and then what what starts
happening that you coincide with return
I became a subscriber to new guard the
magazine of young Americans for freedom
and there was young Americans for
freedom was the conservative student
group right bill Reagan Goldwater
Buckley student conservative group and
so I'll 1970 I read a few issues
and they were really focusing on the
conflict between freedom and order they
had radical libertarian writers and
radically traditionalist writers and I
began to see oh what I like about this
conservatism is the emphasis on freedom
and so that pushed me in a libertarian
direction and then I read I'm Rand and
that pretty well pushed me into the
libertarian camp but I still thought
libertarians were sort of a kind of
conservative and so I got involved in
young Americans from freedom I learned
the editor and regard magazine yeah talk
what what were you what were the issues
when when were you editor and what were
the issues that were really hot in the
moment well I was editor in the late
1970s so the the first and second Reagan
presidential campaigns were certainly a
shaping thing they're a hot issue at
well and an opposing Jimmy Carter and
his energy regulations on the other hand
I actually as a young conservative
libertarian activists in Washington
worked with Jimmy Carter on resisting
the draft until he switched sides and on
the deregulation of transportation so I
was able to say this guy's good on this
but but all this overweening energy
regulation and so on we're against and
you know in a kind of partisan
Republican way as well we're just
against Jimmy Carter and I went to the
Republican convention in 1976 as a
Reagan advocate four years later I
opposed Ronald Reagan because I was
supporting the Libertarian Party
candidate so somewhere in there I had
now transition how what was the kind of
Damascus Road experience where you
realize libertarians are not a virgin or
not a type of conservative but a whole
different species well I did some more
reading I read more Rand I read some
rothbard I ran into ed crane and Tom
Palmer through the libertarian party and
got beaten on by them to understand the
contradictions within conservatism and
began to feel more and more
uncomfortable
Jeff was always undergoing factional
fights and at one point I kind of ended
up on the wrong side of a factional
fight unfortunately had become
libertarian enough to get a job in the
libertarian movement so right there
around 1979 I got my first job in the
libertarian movement and then I jumped
ship to go work for the ed Clark
campaign and really learned how to write
libertarian arguments on behalf of Ed
Clark well and now ed Clark in the 1980
presidential election he scored what a
million votes are nine hundred thousand
nine hundred thousand votes 1.1 percent
yeah and so was the best by far the best
showing a libertarian candidate had
until recently when Gary Johnson did
basically the same numbers a little bit
higher in terms of total votes a little
bit lower in percentage that's right
but what was appealing to you know a
million people base clear one percent of
the voters in an election in 1980
because you know there was Jimmy Carter
there was Ronald Reagan there was John
Anderson
what was it about Ed Clark that managed
to you know polled 1% well 1% is that
somewhat compared relatively speaking
it's pretty good well relatively
speaking I do think Clark came across as
a serious thoughtful guy and he had a
semi-professional campaign which is
probably better than the libertarian
party's done in other years but you have
to say that one of the significant
things he had was money from David Koch
right who was the running mate was the
only way a then multi-millionaire later
billionaire could actually give a lot of
money to a presidential campaign so ed
Clark was able to run as I recall 47 5
minute advertisements on prime-time
network television back when there were
only three networks and that has to be
the explanation but the message was the
American tradition individual liberty
individual rights here is what the
Republicans are doing wrong what the
Democrats are doing wrong it probably he
could have gotten more votes if Ronald
Reagan hadn't been a pretty libertarian
rhetorician that year and i think he
would have gotten more votes if John
Anderson hadn't been there because
Anderson was sort of a liberal
Republican he's not anti-business and
anti free enterprise but he's not one of
those moral majority types and so I
think he took a lot of the attention the
third-party candidate could have gotten
and he took some of the votes of the
socially liberal fiscally conservative
group yeah and the I mean the Clark Koch
campaign they were running on things
like the abolition of the FBI and the
CIA
I don't remember specifically did we say
that we might think so we had a list of
a whole bunch of government programs we
were going I mean it was a wonderfully
hardcore libertarian rescission of
government roles and responsibilities
which seemed to be in keeping with I
mean this was coming out of a decade
where every day you would wake up to a
new expose of just how awful the
government had been and not just simply
miss delivering the mail but in
surveilling people or you know
Watergate and Vietnam yeah finally let's
talk about 2016 we've just come through
a midterm election that was you know
just short of a landslide for
Republicans they now control the house
and the Senate which means that they
will probably reveal themselves to be
utterly contemptible over the next two
years but in 2016 we have people like
Rand Paul who's clearly running or
gunning for the Republican nomination do
you think 2016 is going to be a
libertarian year or will libertarian
issues be front and center I think there
will be a lot of libertarian issues
being talked about
I think endless war is an issue that
certainly Rand Paul will talk about and
other candidates are going to have to
respond to that on the other hand there
may be conservative issues in the sense
that if Isis is still marauding in Iraq
and Syria then there's gonna be a strong
neocon argument that we got to go in and
fight that but yeah I think war will be
I think NSA surveillance is still going
to be an issue on the table that most of
the Republicans would probably just
assume not deal with and the Democrats
too but that if Rand Paul is running
which I'm pretty sure he will be he'll
be talking about and then the general
issues of the size of government what
should we do about inequality what
should we do about poverty all of those
have libertarian answers and gay
marriage may be off the table by then
because the Supreme Court may take it
off and I don't think conservatives are
gonna respond the way they did to roe v
wade and go on a 40-year crusade to
repeal it this is not about the taking
of life this is about letting people get
married and I think after a year of
letting people get married Republicans
will say yeah whatever marijuana might
be a bigger issue probably not a
presidential-level issue because I don't
think anybody's gonna want to take it up
but I do think Rand Paul will be running
and I think he will talk about these
kinds of issues and he will get beat up
by the establishment conservative media
and all the other Republican candidates
and so it'll be interesting to see
whether he can hold up to all do you the
libertarian moment extending it into a
libertarian era or you know more than a
blip it doesn't really turn on whether
or not he's the Republican nominee or
not no that's right we're you know if
historical trends are bigger than any
one candidate now I think we can look
and see if Ronald Reagan had not been
the Republican nominee in 1980 would
things have been different probably so
so it does make a difference but
government programs will continue to
falter the economy will continue to
struggle because of the burdens placed
on it we will continue to get ourselves
involved in unnecessary wars the
president talked in State of the Union
speech about being dragged into
unnecessary conflicts of course he's
bomb seven countries and Bush only
bombed force or he should know but all
of these things will continue to be
problems and if Rand Paul doesn't get
elected president people may decide as
they did with Ronald Reagan boy we made
the wrong decision last time we should
vote for him next time or other
libertarian candidates will surely
emerge we've been talking with David
Bose he's the executive vice president
of the Cato Institute and the author
most recently of the new book the
libertarian mind of revised and updated
edition of libertarian as a primer it's
also subtitled of manifesto for freedom
David Bo's thanks for
thank you for reason TV I'm Nick
Gillespie